hey everyone we're here at Blizzcon and
Alessandra just got to check out
overwatch - and played a little PvE I
believe it yes yeah how was it yeah it's
very much basically in line with some of
the limited time events that they had
you know over the last couple years you
know these limited time events added
these sort of sort of co-op or oriented
like missions where you actually fight
against new sort of enemies like you
know sort of like raging robots or
mercenaries and uh you know it's um it
was very much like that but a lot more
polished like you know it was it felt
very much like a sort of a campaign
mission when like destiny which uh you
know from what they described like you
during the presentation that seems to be
sort of like where they're taking this
game like you know it's more like open
more like you know sort of like
developed hell I game with like you know
single-player content but also the
familiar in depth Mike you know PvP
content oh no one loved cool yeah you
know um they mentioned during the
opening ceremony that's something that
overwatch players want to see more of a
story like a story really resonates with
people in this game and it sounds like
that's what they're trying to bring to
this was it did that feel like you were
working through any kind of like
narrative stuff as you were we only own
robots oh yeah like I'm actually it felt
very similar to leper did you know that
sort of style of storytelling where the
characters are constantly talking to
each other while these events are
happening to them and you know you see a
little bit of that during the PvP like
you know engagements in the original
like overwatch but this one felt a lot
more developed like you know they're
actually having these like sort of
in-depth conversations with all another
wall they're fighting all these robots
and you know they're talking about
themselves their past and everything and
you know of course that was just a very
like you know quick level we got to play
through but um from what we understand
you know the the main campaign will
focus on like sort of the core cast
overwatch characters these so-called
good guys I guess so ya know it's um I
really appreciate the sort of world of
overwatch and uh you know this game is
very much like sort of about sort of
expanding that um it also sounded like
there is going to be some kind of like
character building elements yes did you
get to check out any of that yeah we did
so before the match started we actually
got to sort of pick different like sort
of like perks I guess you can say like I
picked Ryan
and once Scully had was called frenzy so
it was either frenzy or this other
ability that effect it is a sort of like
more ranged attack which could sort of
like you know create lightning damage
for any surrounding enemies but we're
frenzy what happens is if you keep
attacking your your attack speed will go
higher so cool you know basically keep
swinging your mace like you know a
really rapid pace so of course like when
you're playing overwatch like over
several years like any changes to your
character is immediately noticeable in
actually got to interview the developers
today and I asked if those changes will
like you know sort of carry over into
like the multiplayer which is uh you
know the multiplayer is you know four
players with overwatch one and two
they'll be able to share like you know
like the game like you know they'll play
against each other so those like sort of
parks will only be available within the
PvP PvE mode so but it's it sounds like
you get to kind of tune the characters a
little more in the direction of certain
playstyle
oh absolutely yeah like I was really
impressed like sort of like the sort of
the nuances you can add like there's
also like survey's a chest you can find
you know during the mission where you
can pick up a turret or like a special
grenade or like you know sort of like a
you know different like sort of
modifiers for your character and you
know then that will also help like you
know sort of like change the character
like you know like for that particular
mission but also the type of like
playstyle you choose so did you get to
see any new characters how many how many
were available to you in this mini mode
so we just got to pick from like the
more familiar characters like Reinhard
tracer and of course May but you know
the new characters so join which they
just announced at Blizzcon was not
playable in a way so we don't know we
don't know what that characters gonna be
able all about but um you know the new
changes they sort of added to these
characters like the characters that we
know and love you know just makes them
it makes them feel it feels a bit
different I mean like a like you know
horse like you know it's a different
setting to like you know the PvP is
something that you know a lot of old
watch players are very familiar with but
you know the PvE experience like you
know you have to rethink
like how you play some very familiar
care
so that's something I really appreciate
it right yeah and it seems like there's
an advancement in sort of the narrative
even among the characters like everybody
has kind of a new look yeah tweaked up a
little bit so yeah it seems like it's
kind of bringing overwatch forward yeah
yeah it's there a bit sort of like a
vague in terms of like the timeline but
it is very much the next stage of
overwatch and um I'm really pressed
where they're taking over watching like
you know I'm excited to see you know
just how much again bro yeah it sounds
like it's a cool and interesting
evolution of what they built like
overwatch when it was first announced
when it first came out it was it was
felt like a very very specific thing and
it sounds like now that this is bringing
it maybe into new areas that it's never
really been able to go to before you
know you know even with the seasonal
stuff where they like limited releases
yeah it's been dabbling in those places
but now it seems like was it actually
like going all-in yeah it feels like a
fuller game now you know that's not a
dig against the original yeah I'm you
know PvP was pretty fantastic in that
game but you have like so many different
like sort of modes like you know not
just like PvP modes but actual like sort
of expansive like you know story
campaigns and yeah engaging like you
know sort of like a co-op encounters of
another mode they have is the sort of a
hero missions where you the story
missions are very much to set around
specific characters but the hero
missions you can pick every character in
the roster and just level them up and
you go through the depressions okay so
that's overwatch to form or Blizzcon
stay tuned the game spot
[Music]
you